cada vez son menos las personas que hay
aquí en esta sede de campaña del
ingeniero rodolfo hernández que llegaron
de manera espontánea para celebrar el
paso de hernández a la segunda vuelta
presidencial en colombia fue un punto de
encuentro espontáneo porque la sede
principal de la campaña de rodolfo
hernández está nacional de bucaramanga
que es la capital del departamento de
santander está ubicada en el nororiente
del país esta ciudad fue de la que él
fue alcalde en el pasado que representa
su experiencia política y ese es entorno
como alcalde de esta ciudad vale la pena
decir que fueron pocas las personas que
estuvieron acá es una sede regional no
concentra muchas personas pero tuvieron
el espacio para poder celebrar el paso a
esta segunda vuelta muy presidencial hay
que decir que rodolfo hernández llega a
esta segunda vuelta habiendo triunfado
en la totalidad de los dos departamentos
del oriente y del centro del país
excepto en el distrito capital que
también está ubicado prácticamente en el
centro de la geografía colombiana